if you hold your phone camera up to this
QR code it takes you to a website to
register to vote that's pretty cool I
like this shirt but I'm gonna change
into my standard two button polo ah yes
there's the comfort of familiarity good
morning Hank it's Tuesday
so I've been thinking recently about how
weird English is especially when it
comes to prepositions like we use in on
and at as location related prepositions
which is just so weird the general idea
is that in is for big places and on is
for smaller places and at is for
extremely specific places so you live in
a country but on a street and at a
particular address which is a lot to
remember but it's even more complicated
than that because for instance one lives
in a house or apartment because you're
ostensibly surrounded by it or inside of
it but you also live at home unless you
live at school in a dorm room on a
campus similarly you can be both at the
airport and in the airport but you can't
be on the airport unless you're like
Godzilla standing on the airport and you
can be in the airplane or on the
airplane but you can't be at the
airplane although you can be at the gate
and even though in is supposed to be for
large places you can be in your airplane
seat which is one of the smallest places
in the known universe and to make it
worse all these words have other
meanings and shades of meaning like in
can refer to a change of state you break
something in half but it's mostly used
to describe being within or inside
something on generally means on top of
something hence being in a car but on a
motorcycle but on can also be used to
describe the state of something for
instance you can be in a car that is on
fire although I don't recommend it
meanwhile something that happens to my
body superficially usually uses on I was
tapped on the shoulder whereas something
that happens beneath the skin usually
uses in I was shot in the shoulder but
even though is incredibly complicated
and obscure rules sometimes don't apply
see for instance being slapped in the
face
this isn't altogether terrible system
for expressing ideas but generally I
don't notice it because I grew up
speaking English and it's labyrinthine
usage seems completely normal to me I
only noticed preposition choice when it
feels wrong to me like one that's always
bothered me is on the phone why do we
say on the phone to me not that we're
standing on our phones but that we're
using them
on the phone used to mean participating
in a phone call but these days there are
all sorts of ways to be on your phone
you can be texting on your phone or
looking at Instagram on your phone or
playing Fortnight on your phone or
whatever but I would argue that no
matter what you're doing on your phone
you're not really on the phone you're in
the phone when I'm using my phone I'm
not really in whatever physical space I
happen to be occupying and I'm not
really we've whatever physical people
I'm near I'm in the phone with people
who are also in their phones and when I
exit my phone and enter physical space
it doesn't feel like I'm getting off my
phone it feels like I'm getting out of
it and this was the case for me long
before my phone contains so many
distractions and delights and horrors
like when I was a kid and I would talk
on the phone to friends I always felt
like I was not in my house or in my room
but I was in some disembodied space with
the person I was talking to but now
because there's so much more to do in my
phone and also because there's so many
more people in that disembodied space
being in my phone feels thrilling and
terrifying and overwhelming and most of
all weird like I'm not sure of the
language to describe it not only which
prepositions to use but also which
adjectives which nouns I don't know if
understanding leads to language or
language leads to understanding but when
it comes to life in my phone I don't
have adequate understanding or adequate
language all I know is that life on my
phone feels much more like being in a
city than being on an island Hank I'll
see you not in a week or at noon but on
Friday